yeah let's talk about girls a little bit
holy smokes we've been chopping it up
for about 50 minutes all right um yeah
okay so let's talk about the ladies
um
where do we start um what's your life
like with uh dating right now
um so
so right now um
i've been you know i've i've been single
for a while um
and
i
i've i've been pretty like you know what
for me i've been pretty casual so i will
i will uh
you know it takes a lot to capture my
attention now right now i'm actually
seeing someone um but but it takes a lot
to capture my attention so typically
most of the year most of the time i will
go on dates with with different women
maybe have a you know a few girls going
on
and uh and then you know if if i'm not
like crazy about a girl then it's
probably gonna i'm probably just it's
probably just gonna we're gonna hang out
for maybe a few weeks a month and then
it's just kind of gonna fizzle out i'm
not i'm not the kind of person that kind
of keeps a rotation going on for a long
time just because i i kind of i'll get
i'll get bored um and i actually like
like even even like a few months ago i
was like i was felt so happy i'm like
you know what like i i cleared out the
rotation
starting from scratch and so you know i
i i meet girls from from uh i'll meet
girls from instagram and and uh going
out and and uh
is that where you source mostly from
instagram is it dating apps is it girls
that you hire for modeling stuff um i
dude when i was like when i was
like really building my business at 2122
like i i was tender like tinder was like
just was insane especially i don't know
like
it depends on like the i mean back then
it really depend on the city because
that was when the tinder was kind of
beginning but like in toronto tinder was
like like nuts
like
nuts uh toronto and la now i don't
really do as much of the online stuff i
definitely find like
instagram is better for finding like
more like the type of
it's
more targeted for towards my type
yeah pretty much instagram
going out
and uh
and
and that's pretty much it i don't really
i think i've used hinge before um but
nothing nothing that like
use hinge a little bit i know you said
that you watched a a few of my videos uh
last couple of days
did you get across any of the content
that sort of explain you know arousal
and desire with women you know like the
red pill sort of stuff um i've seen some
interviews i don't think i got into into
into that 100 because i mean like what
i'm actually known for is not is not
like doing these podcasts i mean the
podcast is what i enjoy
like the whole reason why i started the
channel guys is because i like hanging
out with entrepreneurs you know with
fast cars and kind of mashing those
ideas up and talking about cars and
business sort of stuff but i kind of
fell into the
like women part of it and and people
know me you know because i'm red pill i
wrote a book called the unplug alpha and
it's sort of you know how you like fix
guys bodies yeah kind of fix their heads
right so guys that have a good body that
have a messed up head that are watching
greg right now and you're not doing well
with women just watch my [ __ ] and you
know it'll come to you or just read my
book but i'm just wondering how how far
through that you got like is there
anything with women that have that that
has you know surprised you or shocked
you or violated like any kind of beliefs
that you had because i mean like his
kids were you know we're sold like a
disney-esque sort of story there's sugar
and spice and all things nice and the
prince and the princess like have you
seen i mean you must have seen some
stuff that's been like wow i didn't know
women were capable of that
uh yeah yeah you know absolutely and i
and i probably was very similar to you
where growing up i had this yeah disney
ideal and and women are freaking perfect
and and amazing and then you kind of
yeah then you then you you know then
you kind of you get your reality checked
in and uh what was your what was your
frying pan of the forehead moment like
your reality check sort of thing
uh you know i i i don't
i don't know like if there was like
necessarily one moment i'm sure there
was like
i'm sure i don't know probably like
dating the first girlfriend whatever
and uh and then you know kind of then
like you know uh first girlfriend and
she kind of just uh
you know she's talking some other guy
and things get a little messy
um but but
you know it's it's
you know it's it's it's very you know
it's you kind of you pretty much realize
that like if you're a high value man you
know what you're doing like
women can get swept up and sleep with
you like
very very easily but then make you know
joe wait till like month number like
after a month or two
um
that's like a kind of like a that's kind
of a realization so like a lot of guys
when they're more inexperienced they
like they get like obsessed over a girl
and like oh like
you know and then and then they get
caught up but they don't they they they
think she acts like that with everyone
they don't know how
she'll act around like
a high value man that kind of knows what
she what they're doing um
yeah um
did you ever have like a moment that
sort of like red pilled you
um yeah no i did i did i i i basically
like i basically
i think like i've i've naturally been
like i've naturally like deep down being
like such a nice guy and like and a good
guy like when i was young when i was
like when i was young even when i first
got tinder i felt guilty talking to two
girls at the same time
literally literally last time until you
figure out their phone is basically a
box of dicks and they're talking about
three dozen guys no i i literally i
literally felt guilty i was like i was
like had this little connection with
this girl and like we're gonna have to
hang out and then some other girls
message me i'm like i'm like i feel bad
you know i shouldn't tell her i'm
talking to another girl i know but then
all these girls are talking to like so
many guys and i just remember whenever i
just whenever i just kind of cut myself
off from all other women and was like
okay like this is the girl i'm talking
to you like this is who i'm into
um things always kind of went went
downhill from there yeah like i just
noticed i just looked at the pattern i'm
like hey like if i if i kind of get
obsessed with this girl and then i stop
kind of i just put all my eggs in her
bat in this basket before we've started
even you know like in the beginning
process it always doesn't work out i
always found that like
you know
not anymore but when i was younger i was
like i was like i was like if i
really really like let's say there's
like two like very very beautiful like i
i'm i'm there's some guys that just like
you know
cute chick is whatever and they just
want to get loads of numbers i don't
care about that for me it's like
complete quality
um until like like
some girls like literally i'm just like
they light me up i'm like damn so like i
remember like i had like two insanely
insanely beautiful
beautiful uh
girls i was chatting with and and um
and like one of them i kind of wanted
more at the time i was like i want her
more
and then didn't work out but then the
one that was like insanely hot still
like that one worked out so it's like
you kind of you it kind of helps to have
like a few going on and a lot of a lot
of times the one you want the most is
the one you you'll mess up especially
when you're learning and then but you'll
get the second best so you know keep
them all all but but the moment i had
that kind of probably uh the kind of
like
uh like woke me up was basically when i
was like i've i formed this connection
with this uh girl here in toronto we
went on a couple dates um hooked up a
little bit and uh i was in la um for
work for a while and like i just like we
just we're facetiming so much facetiming
so so much and uh and then
was that she's keeping an eye on you
that's why she's keeping an eye on me
she's trying to anyway but she would nip
like she you know she would knit when i
make certain comments when i'm just kind
of being a man and making certain
comments um she would kind of nip that
oh you shouldn't say that you shouldn't
talk like that should kind of be trying
to demasculize me
right and i and
i was a bit of a like a [ __ ] at the
time it's kind of like you know that's
what happens to some guys i see them in
the relationships and they get they
slowly get softer they lose their edge
they get called um it's called
pussification by a thousand concessions
yeah and that's and that's also why i
love being single it's a [ __ ] you
just feel like a [ __ ] man you [ __ ]
you know you do whatever you know it's
like it's it feels good you know um but
so i let i let her get you know again i
think it's important if anyone's
retracing their dating history it's like
look like did she no i i let myself kind
of get pussified a little bit anyways
like she she was
the point was that she was back which
was a reading week or she's back from
university and i literally float flew
back to toronto to see her like book the
flight paid the money boom boom boom and
then like and then you know met went to
like meet up with her but like when i
got to tron she's being super distant i
went to meet up with her and then like
she literally like this is when we got
very intimate emotionally and then she
told me like she uh she uh
she told me like she like she was just
being like really distant and like mean
or whatever like [ __ ] and like and
then she like just like yeah sorry i'm
like i got back together with my
ex-boyfriend and
and then but before that she she
mentioned something about her
ex-boyfriend and i was like hey like is
this an issue should i be worried here
this ex-boyfriend thing and she was like
oh no no no no i'm not into him at all
like we had a terrible thing like i'm
not into it all like yes come to like
she was like telling me to come toronto
and then uh and then she [ __ ] pulled
that on me and i just i just went home
and i was like i just felt crushed man
like i really really wanted to see her
and then i was into her and i shared a
lot with her and then she literally just
she she told me that and i mean
this event this hit me hard like hit me
hard and i just remember
like [ __ ] being so pissed and like
even still even though all that [ __ ] i
was like [ __ ] i want to see her like i
got so excited to see her and then i
went on my computer i opened evernote i
did some journaling and i just wrote and
then i just got to that point in like
half an hour and i was just like i got
that point i'm like i was like no she
lost her chance that's it like she she
like that it's almost like a i hit a
switch where i still in [ __ ] mode
and i was like oh i still want to see
her like damn i thought and then i just
hit that switch and then the switch hit
and i'm just like don't want anything to
do with her and guess what
probably i don't know if it's a week or
two weeks later
send a text message hey
didn't respond
hey how are you don't respond
are you mad didn't respond and then i
[ __ ] essays bro got [ __ ] essays
essays essays i never responded
you know what you know what women hate
the most like the thing that motivates
them the most when they misbehave is
what's called a it's either called a
soft next or a hardnecks and the soft
necks you usually do for a few days like
you just ignore them women hate it when
you take away attention right that's
when they lose their mind and they start
writing the essays
um
yeah never she never got it again her
i was at a bar
a year later and her sister came up to
me and slapped me in the face
my sister i was like
what the hell i literally this girl
literally made me fly to toronto then
said sorry i'm back with my ex-boyfriend
yeah and and i'm the [ __ ]
so how old was she
uh she was like i must have been 21
she's probably 19. oh yeah okay so she's
in a party years man she's flipping back
and forth is what she's doing she's
flipping back and forth but also you
know what i made the mistake where i was
entering her frame
and i was kind of getting it's all about
frame
what oh you know about frame dude i i
i'm into the i'm into this stuff man i'm
good you're good but frame is like very
powerful for you know really any any
social contacts yeah yeah it applies to
business transactions uh you know deals
customers women especially like you
definitely want women in your frame like
when she's telling you what to do you
know for example like when you're on you
know the uh face time when you're in la
and she's like oh don't say this and
don't do that you're entering her frame
right you know versus like i don't care
what you think you know sort of thing
which is her coming into your frame um
it's a really interesting dynamic and
when you
and i really wish i knew this stuff when
i was younger like i didn't really get
my head fully around it until i was in
my 40s but guys that are learning this
from me now as a result of watching my
channel or reading my book like like
they're really doing a lot better with
women in their 20s and 30s and they're
not making the stupid mistakes that i
did
and certainly i've noticed that certain
certain women certain even beautiful
women uh
they will they will test guys and one of
the ways they'll test guys is they will
try and take the frame from you
constantly
i've had this not too long ago where
literally this this
girl girl was like
trying to hold the frame like no one
else and you know in little ways and
boss girl
was that one of these boss girls yeah
she was like young and hot but like she
was she was all like taking the the you
know i'd say hey come here and like
whatever she would be
and i like i literally called her on it
i was like i was like what you was like
you have very very strong frame control
yeah i literally told her and it's like
what are you talking about i'm like look
like you like you know usually when i'm
out with women they they try and be
night like like effortless to hang out
with they're they're pleasant they go
below and like you you just like to kind
of be a little combative and stand
offish and uh and i literally called her
on it and i just kind of just kind of
just withdrew my attention and then she
changed immediately yeah
it's amazing how that works so these
like like hashtag boss girls that you
see out there like i'm a boss [ __ ] boss
girl all that sort of stuff it's like
these women are the worst to deal with
because they're going to try to run your
life they're going to want you to enter
their frame they're going to put you
through the beta tization 3000 you know
concessions process and ultimately she's
going to turn you from the you know
she's going to be like oh look i'm with
greg o'gallagher and let's have
thanksgiving dinner with my family look
how hot he is blah blah blah it's
successful and then she'll turn you into
some beta [ __ ] within like six to 12
months with all that you know constant
beating you down with the concessions
that you make over and over again so
it's one of these things that a lot of
guys sleepwalk through in life you know
when it comes to women and relationships
because they do what you know you and i
were sold the bill of lies on which is
well just be a nice guy you know
everything will work out and you know
she'll be in your frame and she'll
compliment your life and she won't ever
you know hurt your feelings or go back
to the other guy you know when you think
that you're flying back to trauma to be
with her sort of thing it's it's really
really interesting when you dive down at
all and you know and that's probably one
of the big
yeah i mean you know if someone off the
bat is just kind of their their
operating system is very very difficult
and that's probably not the girl that uh
you should date like i agree fully um
but you know it is really fascinating
how you know how a lot of a lot i think
the biggest mistake that i i think i see
men make and that i've seen myself fall
into before
is
is you know trying to you know like the
only way to like influence behavior in a
positive way is basically just with your
attention you know and so and and so
like that's kind of the the big
connection that i've made like sometimes
girls will kind of they'll be [ __ ]
testing they'll be taking the frame
they'll be doing this they'll be
and then they'll just try and like
they'll try and chase chase chase and
like that's not the it's not the move to
do that you just gotta just gotta
withdraw there's only you know it's it's
uh
it's it's it's probably the most very
powerful very powerful are you familiar
with the concept of hypergamy
um
to a limited degree and not not
extensively but
all it really means is that a woman's
got to be able to look up to you and and
see that you're the best guy that she
can possibly get with right so right
women date across and up on the
socio-economic scale it's why
you know you're not dating um women that
are equivalent to you or higher you're
dating women that are on the socio
economic scale either at your level or
below
right and guys look at women as beauty
objects women look at guys as success
objects so um what it is essentially
that they're trying to do is throw a
competency test at you which is also
known as a [ __ ] test to see if you're
the best guy that they can get like you
know it like is this guy somebody that's
going to say no to me right like they
want to hear no they're never going to
tell you you know tell me no but they
actually want to hear you no they want
to like get ghosted from time to time if
they misbehave so that they can get put
back in check they'll never tell you
this and you know women watching this
right now or they'll say hey greg you
know i saw that interview with rich he's
lying he's full of [ __ ] but you use it
and you see it work don't worry about it
just watch how they respond to it is all
i tell guys right oh this yeah i know
abs up fact yeah
yeah you know what and and it's it is
true like if you if you look back
historically at times when you've put a
girl on the pedestal and just been
available and and you're like a
celebrity she's going to treat you like
a fan right yeah yeah
even if you're even if you're [ __ ]
brad pitt doing that you can even these
you know even these these like like even
these some of these huge celebrities
that they have they have girl like they
they're they're they're getting simply
for girls
not accelerating not for for some one
person at least um
you